sylvie faucheux a été nommée rectrice de
l'académie de dijon elle était depuis
juillet 2012 présidente du pres go le
pôle de recherche supérieur de
l'université paris-x grant west elle a
aussi officié pendant dix ans en tant
que présidente de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
nous l'avons rencontrée ce matin pour
écouter sa réaction à cette annonce pour
le moins surprise annonces faites lors
du conseil des ministres d'hier réaction
de sylvie faucheux c'était ce matin avec
catherine viola tôt je n'ai pas du tout
candidater puisque impulse avait été
complètement prise dans le développement
dans notre presse université paris xi
faste et donc dans ce jeu bah voilà
c'était surprise effectivement je suis
très heureux c'est une très belle
promotion devenir recteur c'est vraiment
match tfc comme commettre comme devenir
préfet enfin d'autres domaines c'est un
poste a beaucoup de responsabilités
puisque c'est aussi nouveau pour moi
bien entendu puisque un recteur ne se
préoccupe pas que de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche de toute
l'éducation nationale depuis le depuis
le primaire j'y vais demain matin tant
que je prends le nom des premiers trains
demain pour aller à dijon oui il faut
s'organiser vite parce que même au
niveau de la au niveau professionnel
bien sûr je voudrais que j'ai pas chômé
cette nuit pour va essayer de tirer au
clair tous les dossiers faire aussi une
passation de mes dossiers mais aussi au
niveau de la vie privée c'est aussi
d'organisation très rapide pour la
presse je crois qu'on était ça arrive à
un moment opportun c'est pas arrivé la
semaine dernière où on organisait
d'autres séminaires important donc de
rentrer bon
on peut dire que le presse est sur les
rails il y a des projets qui sont lancés
il y à des groupes de travail il y a un
vrai soutien de la part des
collectivités territoriales l'ensemble
des établissements semblent aller dans
le même sens donc bon je pense que ça
arrive à un moment où finalement
peut-être les nouvelles équipes des deux
présidents des deux universités
fondatrice vont pouvoir insuffler à ce
test ce qu'est ce qu'il soit j'ai pas
s'il ya deux méthodes sont les faucheurs
ont d'abord je crois que suis quelqu'un
d'assez tous dias donc je pars d'un
dossier je le fais avec passion là je
craque aussi ça permet d'entraîner les
équipes derrière et je bénéficie
toujours en fait l'équipe qui ne regarde
ni leur temps ni leur énergie les femmes
nous avons plutôt la l'habitude de
travailler pour pour projet en lui-même
et pas nécessairement
en se préoccupant pas ce que les autres
vont penser de nous